[Music]
in 1631
a peculiar copy of the bible was
published it contained one
deeply blasphemous passage earning it
the name the wicked bible at first
glance the book seemed like any other
king james bible at the time
but if you were to turn to exodus 2014 a
passage where they expect to find the
commandment
thou shalt not commit adultery you'll
notice that has been changed
it now reads thou shalt commit adultery
the knot has been taken out so whilst
murder and theft are prohibited
cheating on your partner is apparently
fine
the wicked bible was not the work of
some secret adulterous sect within
christianity
nor did it reflect a lost version of the
original text
in fact it was the product of a simple
but crucial typo
when authorities discovered this blunder
multiple copies of this erroneous
bible had already been published and of
which there are actually 15 still around
today
oh and the publishers they lost their
book printing license swiftly after
the wicked bible is just one of many bad
copies of the good book
it's part of a collection of defective
bibles that have been named
bible errata or bible errors but i like
to call them
biblical bloopers so in this video
let's have a look at some of these
biblical bloopers and perhaps
some errors that have been left
unchanged
with the advent of the printing press in
the late middle ages it became far
quicker and cheaper to produce copies of
the bible one of the earliest bibles
ever produced by the printing press
was the gutenberg bible made sometime in
the 1450s
now previously monks had to
painstakingly copy out entire bibles by
hand
a process that took many years to
complete take for example the irish book
of kells
a beautifully decorated copy of the
gospels from around the year 800
and whilst its ornate pages preserve a
near perfect copy of the latin text
it notably gets a few verses wrong take
for example
matthew 10 34 now it should read
i came not to bring peace but the sword
but the new copy miswrites the latin
word for sword
gladium with joy gaudium
so the verse now becomes something like
i came not only to bring peace
but also joy it's an easy mistake to
make they look so similar when written
down
and plus the verse becomes a lot more
pleasant and certainly
less difficult to interpret
now printing bibles had the advantage
that there's no need to copy out things
by hand
it was a lot cheaper too and hopefully
fewer mistakes
right well as evidenced by the wicked
bible
nothing is quite promised in fact there
are plenty of misprinted bibles
other than the wicked bible so in what
follows
i'm going to prattle off some of the
best or worst depending on your
perspective
so many copies of the king james bible
contain the dreaded blasphemous comma
it occurs in luke 23 32
it describes how two criminals are
executed alongside jesus
in this passage the criminals are called
malefactors
an old-timey word for wrongdoers either
way
the passage should read and there were
also two others
malefactors led with him to be put to
death
yet in some copies the comma is removed
to produce
and there were also two other
malefactors led with him to be put to
death
lacking the appropriate comma implies
that jesus too was a criminal
who indeed deserved to be put to death
punctuation is important folks
much like the wicked bible the
unrighteous bible from 1653
gets rid of an important not before the
word inherit
in first corinthians 6 9 reading know ye
not that the unrighteous shall inherit
the kingdom of god
now this is quite a theologically
controversial message painting the
picture that the unrighteous were the
good guys and thus deserve to go to
heaven
similarly the fool's bible from 1763
amidst the word no at an important
moment
in psalm 14 1 it reads the fool has said
in his heart
there is a god this atheist typo set the
printers back
three thousand pounds
the discharge bible from 1806 replaces
the word
charge for discharge at a particularly
inappropriate moment
in first timothy 5 21. i discharge thee
before god
and the lord jesus christ and elect
angels that's disgusting
moving on my favorite has to be the owl
bible from 1944.
at one point in the book it replaces the
word own
for owl switching the n for the l so
in first peter 3 5 it reads
the holy women also who trusted god
adorn themselves
being in subjugation to their owl
husbands
at face value this biblical passage
implies the existence of a hybrid race
of owl people who apparently spend their
days subjugating human women with whom
they've married
now if anything i'd love to see an
apocryphal book expanding the law of
these mythical beasts
these printing errors are certainly
strange but miscopying the bible
or a biblical text is by no means a new
thing we've already seen how those monks
write in the book of kells were guilty
of god's slip up every now and then
but what about the mistakes that never
got fixed mistakes that have been
preserved in the final edition of the
bible
okay some context might be needed as
they are being written
the biblical texts were passed from hand
to hand and inscribed to scribe
and with each exchange bits were added
and other bits were taken away
now this can need a lot of room for
mistakes say a careless scribe wrote
something wrong
and no one checked up on it the mistake
may become part of the text
and passed down in future copies of the
bible
take for example jesus's name it's
actually well known that jesus wasn't
actually called
jesus but joshua we get the name jesus
from the greek yeasos
eases however is a greek version of the
hebrew name
yeshuva which is where we get our name
joshua
so that's why in the greek translation
of the old testament book of joshua
the main character is also called jesus
speaking of joshua i mean i mean jesus
the new testament jesus
you may have heard of one enigmatic
teaching that
it is easier for a camel to go through
the eye of a needle than for a rich man
to enter the kingdom of god
now this quote has long stumped
interpreters
why such a strange metaphor about camels
and needles
so some have thought that there's a gate
in jerusalem called the ardenidal
where camels would have to take off
their baggage to walk through
but unfortunately there remains little
to no archaeological evidence that this
ever was such a thing
in fact many now believe that all this
is a product of a typo
the first to suggest this was the early
church father cyril of alexandria
who claimed that camel is a greek
misspelling
and that camelos which is the greek word
for camel was written
in place of camilos meaning rope or
cable
so the message actually might have been
it is easier for a rope
to go through the eye of a needle than
for a rich man to enter the kingdom of
god
in my mind at least this seems to make a
lot more sense
it's often the case that translations of
the bible or any text for that matter
distort or warp the original meaning of
the text
just see how the word lucifer was
originally a translation of the planet
venus
or how the many biblical unicorns were
actually wild oxen
i actually have videos on both these
topics so feel free to give them a watch
after this
if these erroneous copies of the bible
reveal anything
it's that you can't trust everything you
read on paper
even if that paper is in the leaves of
the bible try as we might
we humans make mistakes and in the case
of misprinting a holy book
it can lead to controversial funny and
sometimes
outright blasphemous passages it really
gives new meaning to the phrase
the devils in the detail
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this video and welcome if
you're new to the channel
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe
like and a comment also go a really long
way with my university terms starting up
again
i might be a little less frequent in
uploading videos but season 2 is still
continuing
as rest assured there's plenty more to
come
either way i look forward to seeing you
next time goodbye